coming up on this episode of Star Talk
is my exclusive one-on-one conversation
with Kai bird he's the author of
American Prometheus the Triumph and
tragedy of Jay Robert Oppenheimer on
which Christopher Nolan's hit movie
Oppenheimer is based we talk about
Oppenheimer as a person we talk about
his religious beliefs his sensitivity to
The Human Condition we talk about his
and his triumphs about all of his
efforts to build the bomb we talk about
the trial the McCarthyism that
surrounded the distrust of his
associations with the Communist party we
basically flesh out Oppenheimer into the
full person that he was and continues to
be in our hearts and minds and then we
end by
wondering what is the relevance of these
topics as we go into the future are we
at higher or lower risk of nuclear war
than ever before we touch on all of
these topics coming up on Star
[Music]
Talk this is Star Talk Neil degrass
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
today we're gonna have a special edition
featuring my exclusive conversation with
Kai bird who is Kai bird the biographer
of J Robert Oppenheimer in a book that
appeared by back in 2005 called American
Prometheus the Triumph and Tra tragedy
of J Robert Oppenheimer and you know why
we're talking about that because that's
the book on which the movie Oppenheimer
was based welcome to Star Talk Kai bird
well Neil thank you very much for having
me it's a pleasure to talk about
Oppenheimer things
yeah Oppenheimer anything Oppenheimer is
you you're good for it anything
Oppenheimer
so you're a historian a journalist um
and I just this is a I I love your title
here your official title executive
director of the cuni Graduate Center
City University of New York um Leon Levy
Center for
biography whoa so so there's a whole
group of people just thinking about
writing about the lives of others is
that pretty much what you do there
that's exactly what I do we started this
about uh 15 years
ago uh there were a lot of biographers
around the country who complained that
we didn't get respect in the
Academy I get no respect no respect you
know historians didn't weren't taking us
seriously and we biographers believe
that biography as a vehicle is the best
form of History it's the most accessible
it's the most
R and it's deeply
detailed and uh and contained right I
mean biographies tend to be they can be
large volumes but there're still single
volumes typically is that right yeah we
try to make them one
volume you know my biography of
Oppenheimer I did with a co-author who
alas is no longer with us Martin J
Sherwin and Marty spent 25 years on this
biography he only brought me aboard in
the year 2000 and it took us another
five years nevertheless to produce the
book but it's a very timeconsuming
deeply
scholarly Endeavor and as it should
years yes as it should be I mean why not
why wouldn't it be well let me ask a
different kind of question
here suppose you're such a good
biographer that the subject of your book
the person Rises higher than they ever
did did in real life is that
allowed sure no no I ask for example uh
we all know the film Patton and George C
Scott performing in that movie he won
the Academy Award and it's a brilliant
movie and it's a powerful movie but I
don't know that I ever would have heard
of this man were it not for this movie
and then I checked other generals of the
era and he's in there yeah he doesn't
rise up as high as the movie does right
so if you write a brilliant book that
wins a polar surprise if my records are
correct um are who are you to place
someone in a historical Notch that maybe
they either don't belong never deserved
or where does that fit in in the total
uh picture of your of your task well
that's what historians and biographers
do is re-evaluate the the history and
the person and in retrospect often
Jay Robert Oppenheimer the physicist the
father of the atomic bomb is becoming
more and more an iconic figure and more
and more relevant to our own times and
therefore more and more important you
know Christopher Nolan the director who
who wrote the screenplay and directed
the film Oppenheimer uh has been going
around saying that Oppenheimer was the
most important man who ever lived and I
scratched my head for a moment about
that and was wondering I mean
really but the more you think about it
he has a movie to sell just be to be he
does have a movie to sell but uh and I
have a book to sell so to
speak but but you know it's it gave me
pause and I thought about it and you
know Oppenheimer gave us the atomic age
which is never going to go away and
we're always as human beings going to
have to struggle
with the notion of surviving the
invention of atomic weapons remind us
who remind us who Prometheus is because
that's Center to this concept here that
you're describing yes Prometheus was the
Greek god who stole fire from Zeus and
gave it to
humankind and then was punished by Zeus
for this
thievery and he was uh hung on a cliff
and every night a Giant Eagle would chew
out his liver and then it would regrow
and then the whole thing would take o
take place all over again the next day
and he you know he was being punished
tortured for having given humankind fire
and that's exactly what Robert
Oppenheimer did he
gave mankind the atomic fire and then he
was punished nine years later and
dragged through a Security hearing and
humiliated and stripped of the security
clearance and then this was broadcast on
the front pages of newspapers all over
the country another famous book that
uses or references Prometheus is the
subtitle of Mary Shell's book
Frankenstein and yeah what or or what's
the full title is Frankenstein the
modern
Prometheus so I'm fascinated so this is
Dr Frankenstein not so much bringing
fire to the world but creating life this
seems like you're transgressing God or
something right yeah well so Oppenheimer
was
transgressing the gods and that he he
gave human beings the these very
dangerous
mammals uh this weapon of mass
destruction and uh and for that reason
he's the most important man who ever
lived now I so my only I I think he was
a brilliant scientist
coming to this as a scientist I would
have said it a little differently like I
said you have a book in a movie to sell
so I don't want to get in the way of
that plus they're doing well you don't
need me to say one way or another about
it but when I think of systems and I
think of Nations and I think of
geopolitics we were building that bomb
whether it was Oppenheimer or any one of
other dozen people who could have headed
that project who were active physicists
at the time right so so I can't think of
him as uniquely as you are describing
him I can think of him as the project
needed a leader he's a good guy to do it
so you bring him on well actually he was
a most improbable selection uh he never
managed anything more than a half dozen
graduate students for example exactly
yeah and yet uh General Groves the man
who was in charge of the Manhattan
Project selected him uh he was Robert
Oppenheimer was only 38 years old and uh
and yet Grove wasn't old back then
wasn't 38 old back then
no that was pretty young okay fly fly
okay okay okay but uh you know
Oppenheimer Groves saw an Oppenheimer a
Charisma a spark a tremendous ambition
and uh a man who was a scientist a
Quantum physicist but who could speak in
plain English and that was very
important to gross he needed to
understand what was happening and he
realized that Robert Oppenheimer loved
French poetry and the novels of Ernest
Hemingway and and uh you know he learned
Sanskrit so that he could read the babag
in the original I mean he was a polymath
and that's what made him a good
scientist and actually a good
administrator of this Secret City in Los
Alamos that built the atomic bomb would
you say it also gave him a dose of
humanity and humility that might not
have otherwise been there oh absolutely
and you know in biographers bend over
backwards to take iconic historical
figures like Oppenheimer and humanize
them and the film does this too Nolan is
very brilliant at at uh compress ing
into only three
hours don't tell me it was originally
six hours and they cut it back it was a
three-hour movie every minute of it as I
understand it the screenplay as he
originally wrote it was four hours all
right and he had to cut it down to
maintain artistic control in Hollywood
but uh no the film and the book both
bend over backwards to to explain
actually how human and fragile
the young Robert Oppenheimer was this is
a man and this is portrayed in the film
who has a deep
emotional psychic crisis at the age of
22 when he begins to fail for the first
time in his life in the as an
experimental physicist he keeps breaking
things in the lab and and um and then he
suddenly realizes his Forte is not
experimental physics but theoretical
physics and he he's just he happens to
be coming of age just as Quantum is
being discovered it's a whole catalogue
of physicists of the era who all had a
were touched by or touched quantum
physics which was being invented in real
time in the 1920s and early 30s so it's
it was a it was a remarkable period in
physics I try to let people know that we
are in the Centennial decade that's
right of the discovery of quantum
physics and that was AED deade not only
the quantum but Hubble discovered that
there's more than one galaxy in the
universe and that the universe is
expanding all that happened in the 1920s
it it's incredible yes and yet most
Americans most people do not understand
quantum physics and still still still
it's hard it's hard to describe and the
film I think I'd be interested in your
opinion of this uh the film I think
makes a really Valiant attempt to
visually explain quantum physics at one
point they he has the young Robert
Oppenheimer as a young physicist and uh
wandering through a art gallery and
comes across a Picasso painting that's
in the
Cubist mode uh and he's staring zoom in
on it yeah and they zoom in on it and
they zoom in on it and of course this is
a metaphor Nolan is using Picasso's
painting as a metaphor for Quantum and
how different it it forces you to look
at the world it's a disruption of
perspective which cubism would was to
Art there have been some art historians
who have analogize the two as arising in
in approximately the same era and I I
think they tried to mention a cause and
effect I'm less convinced of that but
I'm intrigued that they did correspond
it was the era of Rel ity are you
looking at the front of someone or the
side of their head or the back of their
head there a lot of modern physics that
was disrupting our sense of what is
normal and what isn't and the art world
was I think on some of the same track
there all so let me ask you about the
the let me give you my reaction to some
parts of the film okay the as a
scientist I know most of the Oppenheimer
story so but I'm not one of those oh
they got that wrong or I'm not that guy
okay I'm not that guy um but what I did
notice and is this you in your original
writings or is this Christopher Nolan
who by the way um if you allow me to
give a quick commercial we interviewed
Christopher Nolan on Star Talk some
years ago um when we were just talking
about how many films he's done that
disrupt the timeline of events right in
the world so he's he's a very good
Sci-Fi thinker in that regard and we had
a wonderful conversation with him and
you can find it uh on in our archives
just search for Nolan and you'll go
straight there so what I found is the
movie is
full of
these these simple
gestures of
scene of script line of Gest of of of
movement of camera angle that capture
some interesting fact about the
era and and to to to accomplish that
without it looking
forced I thought was brilliant and I'll
just give one simple example okay okay
Richard feeman yeah plays the Bongos and
he's not identified and he's not
identified and there's a scene where
there's at a party and there's just some
guy there you look from and from behind
and he's playing the Bongos it's it just
it just goes by it doesn't zoom in on
here is Richard fan you all heard no
it's just a guy just a guy and uh Nolan
expects the
audience to wonder about that and to
maybe go and find out who was that guy
playing the Bongos was that real or not
is he given too much credit for the
audience to dig up that level the
movie's full of those details is my
point right yeah oh Al I've seen the
movie five times now and each time I see
it I see new layers new
little and and and the and you and you
wrote the damn book
yes and it's only 720
pages so another one is again fan goes
un un um I mean the the actor who plays
fan is credited in the end credits I
State through them all but fan is not
identified as a character in the story
itself right and there's a scene where
there's someone sitting in the car
that's right as they're all slathering
themselves with the the UV block for
this explosion and it's sitting in the
car and they said you want some of this
and he says no uh the the windshield
blocks nearly all of the UV this is a
physics fact physicists we all know this
but that was famously written in one of
Fan's biographies that's right and
that's fan say that and with a good
rejoinder well okay the the window
blocks the UV but what blocks the
window well in the in the explosion so
so I little things like that um were
persistent throughout the storytelling
and he stitched it all together smoothly
I didn't feel anything was forced and
all of the elements of this little
things like the uh we knew that in
Germany there was a a Hitler and that
sort of the racist regime that that was
they elevated experimental physics to a
higher level than theoretical physics
and so the Jews were relegated to the
theory because that wasn't as high
ranked and so that would include
Heisenberg and and Einstein and all
these folks right and so there's that
one place in the movie where they say oh
he'll be uh if we know know this and
Heisenberg will know it and they say no
he's Jewish and they don't give him
access to the lab right and so boom
that's that's that that encapsulates an
entire world viiew that the Nazis had
but you you can't offramp to that in a
movie that's through the POV of
Oppenheimer but you can throw a bone to
it and that's the examples of what I'm
saying here yeah it's incredible that
Nolan has weaved all this into the film
and there
you know I
I I've seen it five times as I said and
I read uh the screenplay before they
started to film and he wanted me to do
that to identify any gross errors and I
I couldn't find any this it's remarkable
in
a he's a he wrote the screenplay yeah
he's a good he wrote he wrote the
screenplay and it's you know it's
accurate okay now I did find an
inaccuracy and I tweeted about it I just
thought I'd tell tell you okay what' you
find let let me just say I let off the
Tweet by saying he got so much correct
that I give him a hall pass on this next
okay okay um so he's in the desert on
July 16th all right this is three weeks
after the summer solstice uh the summer
has the
longest um Twilight of the year it's
5:30 in the morning he would have been
well into Twilight at 5:30 in the
morning and would not have been pitch
dark but I give it to him because now he
gets to have the explosion against
complete
darkness there it is I get Grant him
that artistic license are are you sure
you took into account daylight savings
time so even including daylight savings
time that's okay yeah yeah I totally
took that into
account hi I'm Neil degrass Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and I'm Lindsay
Nix Walker senior producer of Star Talk
and Neil and I just co-authored a brand
new Star Talk book coming out September
12th yeah this is the third in a series
of collaborations with National
Geographic books and this one is titled
to infinity and beyond and it's
available for pre-order from the stalk
website stalk
media.com books if you pre-order it you
get to gain access to a live stream that
Lindsay Walker and I will do from this
office and you have the occasion to
submit questions that we will answer
that's right if you pre-order from stalk
media.com books we'll answer your
questions about the book The Universe
Neil's favorite kind of cheese whatever
you want
all right so we'll see you there and
we'll see you
then so so as a biographer you don't
always know necessarily in advance
you're going to be writing about a
scientist so how do you you know you
know how to think about people and
places and relationships I presume
that's a baseline for you as an author
and as a biographer and as a journalist
but now there's a subject matter science
is as much a subject as the person
Oppenheimer is so how do you do your
research to get the right amount of
science into the biography of a
scientist well that's an interesting
question and uh precisely because it's
so hard or it's a different level of
research that needs to be done when you
choose a
scientist at my biography Center at at
city un University we give out four
fellowships a year to working
biographers and we've now established a
fifth that is funded by the Alfred Sloan
Foundation that is dedicated exclusively
to doing biographies of scientists okay
so Sloan has a strong science right
leaning in their funding so that makes
complete sense here and we did that
because there's sort of another mountain
to climb uh if you're a biographer when
you're trying to write about a scientist
so coming back to Oppenheimer you know
I'm I'm the guy in college who took a
course in physics but it was called
physics for poets
okay I confess so I don't understand by
the way I I heard this just to slip this
in here there's Newton's laws of motion
and one of them uh is for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
that's one of Newton's three laws so I I
was told this by someone who took
physics for poets that there's a
poetical version of that law and it's
you cannot touch without being
touched okay that's that's beautiful
that's beautiful good good poetry good
science I had that problem TR trying to
as the
biographer writing about aer's love life
his politics his education his
privileged background growing up in New
York City but also his science is
difficult how do you explain what he was
doing with quantum physics in the late
20s and 30s and black hole Theory and um
and it was it
was very difficult um and particularly
difficult to try to be able to
explain some of this uh some some of his
writings about physics and uh in plain
Eng English in in a language that people
could understand in a biography and
anyway among the mountains you you
scaled that's one of them
yep okay absolutely now your book came
out in ' 05 the pullit surprise would
have given its sufficient visibility at
the time Christopher Nolan is making
films around then I think why did it
take so long to show up on the Silver
Screen uh no one handed him the book
until early
okay okay okay you know uh it's the
uncertainty principle at
work I see what you did there
okay uh you know things happen by chance
and yes Nolan turns out to have been the
perfect director because of what you
just said earlier that he's always been
interested in his film work about issues
of time and space and memory and uh and
so he would he he got this book by by
pure chance um in early 21 read it not
from you not from me no okay it it came
actually through the a businessman who
had studied physics actually at MIT who
bought the film option back in 2015 and
tried over you know
six seven years to get the film made and
and was failing and finally he went got
in the middle of the pandemic went on a
private jet out to California and uh
This Is A Man Named Dave
Wargo uh and he he just had a passion
for the subject and he flew out to
Hollywood and had one contact there who
happened to be a producer for for Nolan
and that guy uh handed the book to
Christopher Nolan he read it and Nolan
without contacting me or Marty uh sat
down over the spring and summer of 21
and wrote
a very long screenplay and then the
first I heard about it was in September
of 21 and he he called me up and said
that he had picked up the film option
he'd written a script and he was going
to do
it and you did you know did you know of
him at the time as director did well I'd
seen The Batman Trilogy I'd seen momento
I I'd seen Interstellar so okay all
right so you knew his portfolio yeah
yeah well I think he was the right guy
to do this and I think possibly even at
the right time because the nuclear
proliferation and the risk and tensions
around the world now make the nuclear
age um much more relevant today than
even just a few years ago this could
sensitize people in a way that matters
going forward no we're worrying about
Putin threatening to use tactical nukes
in the Ukraine it's just it's
astonishing right right so let's so uh
the movie is two it's basically two
movies there's the bomb and then there's
the trial or just his his experience is
your book book split in that same kind
of way well you know like most
biographies it's told chronologically
okay so therefore it would be but uh you
know it's I'm very happy with the way
the film came out because at one point
when just after I joined Marty Sherwin
on his 20year project at that point uh
in the year 2000 he at one point turned
to me and he said you know you and I
wouldn't be spending all these years
writing this long biography if it was
just a story about the father of the
atomic bomb if it was just about
building the hbomb the atomic bomb and
of course there's already a book with
that title the making of the atomic
bombad by Richard rhods right but also a
p prizewinning book by the way that's
right that's right and uh but Marty said
that what made it really compelling as a
story was the arc the fact that
Oppenheimer in 1945 was hailed as
America's most distinguished scientist
his cover his image was on the cover of
time and life and and then nine years
later he's brought down and humiliated
in this trial this Kangaroo Court
proceeding and he becomes a public non-
entity that's what makes the story
really interesting and of course it's a
story about
McCarthyism so that's a story about our
divisive politics today so it's all of
One Piece it's really Rel resonance yep
but so why because we all knew that
McCarthyism was the backdrop but
McCarthy himself spent all his time
bringing up like actors and you know uh
no one so heroic as Oppenheimer in the
yes and no okay because in 1953
54 uh one young Roy
Cohen McCarthy's chief of staff tried to
subpoena Oppenheimer he wanted him to
testify as to his communist leanings see
what's behind my question is at no time
in the film unless I missed it but I was
pretty attentive no one even mentions
McCarthy that's right that's just the
it's a framing of this right and so my
my sense was well is this all happening
above McCarthy's pay grade right it was
exactly that's a good way to put it
right I mean we're not talking about
security clearance for Hollywood actors
who you want to Blacklist right we're
talking about something that involved
the military the White House and all
these other layers yeah no the
Eisenhower Administration and Dwight
Eisenhower the president himself made a
decision that they had to bring down
Oppenheimer because he was going public
as America's most prominent scientist in
his opposition to the building of the
hydrogen bomb and to continued Reliance
on nuclear weapons as a defense he said
famously just three months after hosha
he said these are weapons of Terror
these are weapons for
aggressors they were weapons that were
used on an essentially already defeated
enemy so you know he was speaking some
really tough hard truth to the American
public and this antagonized the American
defense establishment the generals the
Pentagon and Eisenhower Eisenhower
because Eisenhower famously in his
speech what is it called the exit speech
what that's called something what is it
his Farewell Address yes he he coined
the phrase military-industrial complex
that's he warned us that if you build up
an entire industry that's equipped for
war then and it's an economic part of
our nation then it would never go away
and you'd always have to be fighting
Wars to support it and so I would think
he would have a slightly
more um charitable view of oppenheimer's
thoughts but that wasn't the case well
it wasn't the case early in his an
Administration in 1953 and 54 because
Eisenhower uh latched on to the notion
he became convinc that Atomic weapons
are cheap and that they would represent
a cheap defense
uh vers Visa the Soviet Union and
preparing and deterring a a threaten
Soviet land invasion of Western Europe
and of course we now realize that these
weapons are not cheap we're now spending
over the next 10 years a trillion
dollars to modernize our current nuclear
weaponry and so these weapons are not
cheap and uh Eisenhower was wrong about
that and he became convinced by Lewis
straws the man that he appointed as
chairman of the atomic energy Commission
in
1953 uh he straws convinced Eisenhower
that Oppenheimer was a security threat
and in any case he was someone that
needed to be brought down because he was
opposing their uh desire to build more
of these weapons and specifically the
hydrogen bomb yeah and the hydrogen bomb
you know is 10 to 100 thousand times
more deadly and that's a whole other
world right yeah oh much
worse so here's an interesting
question uh and this was brought up in
random banter it wasn't random in some
of the banter of the film and and it's
been discussed among
historians that Truman just viewed the
atom bomb as just another weapon in the
Arsenal of a war not a specially deadly
weapon of course it was more deadly than
others but they made it clear just a few
weeks earlier we had firebomb Tokyo
killing a 100,000 people and this bomb
would not even kill that many so so are
we to believe or understand that
Oppenheimer didn't see this as just the
next weapon in war that he really saw
this as some kind of prum through which
we walked and could never return Yes
oper understood that
uh from the even before Trinity even
before Hiroshima Nagasaki he understood
that this was an extraordinary weapon
that would change things in fact his
Hope was that it would be be perceived
as so awful such a terrible weapon that
it would end all war um and of course
you know that was the hope it's still
it's still the hope of many people
Truman had uh a much more simple
understanding um and his you know he he
thought it was a weapon that would help
to end the war but you know after
reading about what had happened on the
second the fact that a second Japanese
City had been hit at
Nagasaki uh Truman actually noted in his
diary that he had given the order to
stop any further use of these weapons uh
because he couldn't he couldn't bear the
thought of all those women and children
being killed this is in his private
diary so even Truman begins to evolve
and have an A a clear understanding of
the extraordinary awfulness of this
weapon and yet there is that scene in
the film where Oppenheimer tries to come
into the Oval Office and explain that we
should be concentrating on control
regulation disarmament ban the bomb and
druman turns to an interrup UPS him and
says well Dr Oppenheimer when do you
think the Russians are going to get the
bomb and Oppenheimer says well in a few
years and Truman says no no never he
thinks that the Russians aren't capable
of producing this and aimer tries to
argue you know they have good physicists
too it's yes science doesn't know
National borders exactly yeah it's one
the secret is out everyone knows that
this can be done and he actually gives a
speech around this time publicly in
which he thinks you know he says you may
think that these weapons are very
expensive because we spent two billion
dollars on them but they are actually
cheap in that any country however poor
that wants to build these weapons will
be able to do so it's just an
engineering problem the physics is all
known yes that point was made definitely
now let me ask you uh what's the term
that you guys use uh count counter
historical counterfactual counterfactual
so thank you so let me offer a
counterfactual scenario um if someone
other than Oppenheimer were chosen as
head of the Manhattan
Project whether or not it would have
been interesting material for you to
write a book on uh do you think the
project would have gone any differently
than it
did well yes and Oppenheimer would you
know was a much more interesting
physicist to write about because he's
well that's what I'm
saying in a counterfactual world it
doesn't care about you
yes care about history okay yeah no he's
much more interesting of course
Oppenheimer was
endlessly complex and an interesting man
to write about but if he had not been
chosen as scientific director at Los
solos they would have chosen someone
else and the work would have been done
probably not as quickly as he was able
to build the gadget probably not within
two and a half years probably not by the
end of the war so it would have C
happened after the end of World War II
and that actually poses a another
interesting
counterfactual because if the bomb
hadn't been demonstrated during World
War II in combat then oppenheimer's fear
and Neils B's fear the famous Danish
physicist Quantum physicist Their Fear
was smuggled who they smuggled out of
Northern Europe right that's right in a
in a small
airplane uh Their Fear was that the next
War would be fought
by armed adversaries both of whom would
be armed with nuclear weapons and this
you know this would be Armageddon
because people wouldn't realize what a
genocidal weapon this was so what is it
about Oppenheimer that you think had
him make turn this into an efficient
operation because the military is all
over it right I mean they're you know
military gets stuff done when they need
to get stuff done that's right because
the money is Flowing like rivers in a
war effort so why are you so confident
that someone else would have taken
longer well everyone that we interviewed
at Los Alamos who was there at the time
they always made a point of telling us
this that OPI was just
extraordinary um and that they had
numerous mountains to climb in building
this gadget and technical issues to
solve engineering problems and
Oppenheimer was simply good at sort of
standing back at the of the room and
letting everyone letting his scientists
argue for 30 minutes 40 minutes an hour
and then would step in precisely at the
right moment and summarize in plain
English the options and where the path
forward was and he was charismatic he
motivated people to work hard and to
play hard at Los Alamos and it just you
know he it's extraordinary that you know
only one physicist quit and walked away
and that was Joseph blat who decided
that he didn't want to have anything
more to do with this when he learned
from General Groves that uh in late 1944
that the the gadget was probably going
to be used on Japan not Germany because
the Germans were so close to being
defeated so at that point he walked away
but
Oppenheimer he persuaded his scientists
to stay on the job to work even harder
and precisely because he wanted to see
this weapon demonstrated at least maybe
not in combat but demonstrated during
this war so that the next War wouldn't
be fought with nuclear weapons so in the
second half of the movie where we see
basically the trial of Oppenheimer um
that's very different material to work
with relative to
physicists knocking heads trying to
build the most destructive weapon ever
it's people sitting in a room having a
conversation so in your
biography did you use any special
tactics for the reader to keep them
interested or was the subject matter so
enticing all on its own that you just
simp simply needed to recount it and
that would work as as the pros of your
of your work well that's a good question
but I I think the answer is that you
know it was a courtroom drama and as a
courtroom drama the actual testimony
from of all the participants of
Oppenheimer of Lewis straws Groves it's
it's there and it's very dramatic and
and and uh Christopher Nolan actually
uses straight out of the transcripts
much of the dialogue for the right so no
disrespect but that whole part of the
story wrote itself is you're saying
exactly I'm I'm confessing that was the
easiest part I just told you the hardest
part was to describing quantum physics
okay so what I thought was odd is in the
narrow interrogation room um Oppenheimer
is always on the back couch while people
are are testifying is this would he have
been in the room at the same time is
that a oh yes oh yes that was everything
nothing was normal about this answer
yeah it wasn't a courtroom proceeding
they make that clear in the movie too it
was you know a Security hearing no rules
applied um but yes he was there to
defend his right to have a security
clearance just to be clear it was not a
literal courtroom but the story unfolded
The Way courtroom drama unfold exactly
with the Dynamics of the questioner and
the and the the squirming person who's
just been questioned and yeah okay just
to be yeah exactly no it was a tiny
little room uh and with there was a sofa
and Opie sat there with often with Kitty
by his side listening to this awful
these awful accusations that he was Kami
spy
perhaps not worthy of a security
clearance what the movie also threw a
bone to and I don't mean that to
belittle it just because it's a the
movie has so much to talk about it can
only just briefly address what
ultimately are very important facts that
um not all communism is the same right I
mean you you can there there variations
of Communism that the American
government would find offensive and then
there's parts of Communism where you
just care about the worker who's being
abused by by you know management or
something so I thought that was
addressed would you agree yeah I think
that came across very effectively you
know OPI was you know he was he was a
science nerd in the 20s and then his
girlfriend Jean tatlock
you know made him guilty for not caring
more feeling empathy for what was
happening politically movement in the
midst of the depression and uh and so
you know he be became active in Berkeley
issues like trying to help to
desegregate a public swimming pool in
Berkeley and this was a project of the
local Communist party uh he helped to
raise money to send an ambulance to the
Spanish Republic in the midst of the
Civil War in
1936 I mean these are the kinds of
issues that motivated him to contribute
to causes of the Communist party and
that that came across right because they
said did you give money to the Communist
party I gave money to a cause that they
managed right that that was clear very
clear and in the you know in the in the
book we go into great detail trying to
wrestle with the mystery of whether he
actually join the party and Marty and I
weighed the evidence and decided that
really you know he wasn't a joiner he
was a free intellectual he discouraged
his own brother Frank from joining the
party Frank did it anyway um and yes he
contributed you know as much as $400 a
year to sort of Communist party
activities but he was a man of the left
in the 1930s which was not Not Unusual
yeah not weird
and something you may know I only know
because my father was active in the
civil rights movement of the
1960s that so much of Martin Luther
King's efforts was to bring dignity and
suitable compensation to the
workingclass black person in America uh
and the people who would have been
ideally suited to attempt that would
have been the American Communist party
because it's all about workers and but
the movement knew that you can't have
Communists leading this movement because
it would be squashed because communist
are you know the the official Communist
Party Line denies God and all the rest
of this so you get a preacher to lead
this right if you get a preacher to lead
the labor movement then you can't say
he's communist because he's he's a
preacher right so there was tactical
steps invoked just to protect yourself
against what would otherwise be a
government which already did happen
anyway but yeah yeah I think civil
rights leaders at the time understood
the lessons of the M McCarthyism and the
lessons of the Oppenheimer trial you
know you do not want to be tarred and
feathered as a red right um and actually
you may raised an interesting point
because Martin Luther King at one point
early on he had a close adviser named
Stanley levenson who was uh member of
the Communist party and the FBI knew it
and you know he had to gently get
distance himself from his relationship
with Levens precisely for that reason
right right and uh uh two other points I
want to go back to something just
briefly um so was it a tactical decision
for the film if not your book to make no
specific mention of
McCarthy
oh you know the film those McCarthy
trials were going on at the same time as
what was being portrayed oh yeah and the
famous Army McCarthy hearings televised
hearings were that spring of 54 so uh
yeah I think you know Nolan's film is
very complicated it's conveying a lot of
complicated history and this is hinted
at but you don't need to go you know
it's not a film about McCarthyism it's a
film about what happened to Oppenheimer
now in the book we we talk a lot about
what Joe McCarthy was doing and Roy con
and um and their attempt actually to
subpoena up and imer which was thwarted
actually by the Eisenhower White House
who sent over the vice president one
Richard Nixon to uh explain to Joe
McCarthy that he really was getting in
the way they had other plans for dealing
with Oppenheimer I the Security hearing
there it is yeah yeah yeah so
um and I'm a little jealous that you're
calling him
Opie do I do I get to call him Opie or
do I have to be his biographer to be on
a nickname basis with the man you just
have to like the guy so all his students
called him Opie okay all his closest you
know colleagues all right uh Kitty his
wife called him Robert
but okay I'll be in Spirit I'll I'll
think of him as Opie then I'll bu real
close to him so um we're running short
on time here do you have any just any
any Reflections you want to share that
might give insight to those who either
haven't seen the film yet or don't know
much about Oppenheimer I mean you would
have deeper insights than practically
anyone in the world on this just think
something to think about going forward
reflecting on the past well I I would
just like to emphasize that the story of
Robert Oppenheimer is a story for our
time
it's a story about our fear of nuclear
weapons which we're still grappling with
you know the atomic age began with
Oppenheimer and the story could end
badly uh it's a story about politics and
McCarthyism which we're still living
with because Joe McCarthy explains a lot
about one Donald
Trump uh and it's also a story about the
role of Science and Technology in our
our society we're drenched with science
and techn lives and in geopolitics right
yes and yet uh Mo many of our citizens
don't seem to understand science and uh
part of the reason I'm convinced this is
true is that we don't have uh we don't
value scientists as public
intellectuals and we don't give them a
platform on which to get up and explain
and debate the consequences of science
so we're seeing this beginning to happen
with the debate over the the
implications for artificial
intelligence um but we need more of this
and this was Illustrated most
dramatically during the pandemic when
Public Health officials like Anthony
fouchy were tarred and feathered
politically and their patriotism
questioned and their honesty questioned
in the same way that
oppenheimer's integrity was question
questioned in the 19 you're saying we
haven't learned a damn thing we haven't
learned a damn
thing on that happy
note sorry okay well I mean your book
and then the film uh of course these are
two different marketplaces the people
love to read and the people who only see
movies um we get to hit them on both
sides with these very important
contemporary issues because everything
old is new again yeah well kyberd it's
been a delight to have you as my guest
on Star Talk uh in this exclusive
conversation uh let me remind people uh
Kai bird along with uh the late Martin
Sherwin is author of American Prometheus
the Triumph and tragedy of J Robert
Oppenheimer came out in 2005 won a pol
surprise on which the recent Christopher
Nolan film Oppenheimer is based and
you're the executive director of the
cuni Graduate Center we all love CUNY
here uh at the Leon Levy Center for
biography and I'm delighted to even know
that exists as a thing so Kai thanks for
being my guest well Neil this has been a
lot of fun thank you for having me
excellent I'm Neil degrass Tyson your
personal astrophysicist as always keep
looking
[Music]
up